OK. So, we have the Will Smith, Abe Hiroshi duo, and he's an actor. They're both actors which you admire.
Yeah, definitely.
Will Smith isn't the first name that comes to your head when you think of somebody you'd like to emulate?
He's definitely, probably the first person I think of, but...
...my style, I hope I can, you know, have a range like say, Will Smith,...
...Johnny Depp takes some really unique roles.
Yes, he does.
I would say him. I would definitely say Laurence Fishburne.
Ah?
Yeah, 'cause he plays really obscure roles, just things you would never think of.
And there's a lot of new actors that are coming up anyway, when you're taking a look at him and saying, "He's really good."
Like "Hurt Locker," have you seen it?
Not seen it, I don't know.
Definitely should watch it.
It is a bit heavy, though.
Yeah.
It's a bit heavy but the acting is really good.
Really?
Yeah.
And there's an actor there whom I should pay attention to?
Yeah, as a matter of fact, if you're into comic book movies, I'm kind of a geek,...
...he's gonna be playing Hawkeye in the new Avengers movie.
Really?
So I'm gonna let you find out who it is and then you tell me.
OK, you don't know his name?
I do, but you need some homework.
OK, I'll do that.
'Cause I wouldn't be surprised that you don't interview him soon.
'Cause I'm pretty sure he'll be coming here to promote another movie. I think "The Town".
OK.
Yeah.
I saw "The Town".
Yeah, he's there.
OK, so that narrows it down.
Yes, it does.
I like "The Town". It was good, yeah, hard-boiled action movie.
Ben Affleck kills people without much ado. He just walks in and kills people.
Yeah.
It's great.